every time I dance I try to do my best
and I give the most because living in
the ward taught me maybe this time it
will be the last dance for you Abby will
be killed in a bomb or a bullet or
something when you leave the studio so
every time I would give my best and live
it to the most
[Music]
Ahmed judo was born in the Yarmouk camp
a refugee camp for Palestinians in Syria
despite his tumultuous surroundings he
found escape in a hobby uncommon in his
culture
I saw dance for the first time when I
was a child eight years old because I
was fascinated by their movement and by
the music that they are moving I learned
how to dance through videos on YouTube
and I was doing this every day in my
room secretly because dancing in my
collector especially for a man it's
something to be ashamed of my life was
in danger when I was in Syria because I
was a dancer and that's because of the
extremist people who came into our
country and then I would start to
receive all these messages or phone
calls or those kind of things that
telling me they want to cut my head and
that's why I have my tattoo dance or die
of mine
as I carry my life on my neck and if
they would have kill me I wanted it to
be the last thing they can see from me
so it's dance or die while in Syria
Achmed went on to receive formal dance
training and would post videos of his
dancing and was eventually discovered by
a documentary filmmaker from Holland who
wanted to tell his story the film is
seen by the Dutch National Ballet who
offered him a scholarship he has since
gone on to perform all over Europe
we are here in killed in theaters
talking about social media in this
production I'm acting myself because
social media played the most important
role in saving my life in my story
because through social media I was seen
and I was rescued
[Music]
what made me keep dancing and keep on
doing what am i doing even until today
because I believe the artist has the
same duty like the soldier to fight for
his country and the artist can fight for
character and for art and for history
and if we don't have art and culture in
our countries what are we fighting for
away from thence I am nothing and I have
nothing all I have is this and all I am
is the dancer and maybe in the far
future sometimes I see myself sitting in
the chair as an old man in theater at
Syria directing the Syrian National
Ballet that I will find so I hope this
dream will come true
[Music]
you